so i think it's not that we fear death i
think it's that we fear not
living the life that we want and i think
the easiest way to get out of that it's
not easy is just to start living the
life that you want now not putting it
off and and that's i'm guilty of that
too everyone's guilty that we just put
off our lives
someone asked what are your fears um
and do you think about life after death
those are highly related so it's late at
night so let's get philosophical
i think everyone's fear ultimately
all fears are
children of the fear of death the fear
of death is is the big one
and
it's it's good question to ask why
do we
fear death what what are we so afraid of
after all every night when you go into a
deep sleep you're essentially dead you
don't remember anything from the deep
deep sleep um you might as well be dead
during that period of time before you
were born it was like being dead
if you've ever been knocked unconscious
either through general anesthesia or
just some kind of trauma
you're essentially gone from this world
so it's not the experience of death that
i think we fear because
there's no one there to experience it
there's not even the experience of
necessarily of loss because you don't
you don't experience anything when
you're dead
but
i think what we're really afraid of when
we die or when we think
we're gonna die
um is
we're sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna block
somebody here all right um
what we're afraid of when we think we're
gonna die
is uh
we're actually asking for more time
we're basically saying no no wait i'm
not ready to go yet
and why are we saying we're not ready to
go yet so i think it's more that we feel
like we haven't really been living we've
been putting off our life
um if you were living your ideal life
and if you were going through joy or
happiness or bliss all the time
if your life was fulfilling moment to
moment then i don't think you would
really fear death first is you'd be too
busy to fear death you'd be too busy
living and second is i don't think you
would have regrets life is actually
really long it's really really long
it's just that we waste it we fritter it
away we fit it away because we're um
you know doing things that we think are
low value or we're mortgaging the the
present uh to try you know for some
imagine future but i think if you're
truly living your life on your terms the
way you want it and you're happy you
will find that life is long and you are
less afraid of death
so i think it's not that we fear death i
think it's that we fear not
living the life that we want and i think
the easiest way to get out of that it's
not easy is just to start living the
life that you want now not putting it
off and and that's i'm guilty of that
too everyone's guilty that we just put
off our lives
i don't know if that was helpful
i feel like everything i say now is just
trite it just feels so obvious to me
[Music]
you